ang quantum entanglement ay nagpapahintulot sa mga particle na magkonekta anuman ang distansya sa pagitan nila — napaka-counterintuitive nito
na kahit si Einstein ay hindi naniniwala dito sa episode na ito ng Qiskit in the Classroom, pag-uusapan natin kung paano pinatunayan ng Bell's
theorem na mali si Einstein
maligayang pagdating sa Qiskit in the Classroom sa seryeng ito, gagamitin natin ang Qiskit upang tuklasin ang ilang pangunahing konsepto na karaniwang
tinatakpan sa mga kursong nauugnay sa Quantum Computing kasama ng bawat video ay isang interactive na module
na naka-link sa paglalarawan sa ibaba kaya siguraduhing tingnan iyon sa video ng quantum coins, tinalakay natin kung paano ang pagsukat ng
quantum superposition ay isang likas na probabilistikong proseso tulad ng pagtapon ng barya sa ilang paraan ngunit paano natin malalaman
ito maaari bang ang isang quantum particle ay lihim na nagtatago ng isang paunang natukoy na resulta ng pagsukat ngunit sa anumang paraan ay nabigo tayong
makuha ang impormasyong ito sa ating teorya sa maagang panahon ng quantum mechanics ang tanong na ito ay paksa
ng mainit na debate na may dalawang pangunahing pangkat sa isang kampo ay si Einstein na naniniwala na ang quantum mechanics ay hindi kumpleto
ibig sabihin ay may mga nawawalang variable na kailangan upang ganap na ilarawan ang isang sistema inisip ni Einstein na
ang mga tinatawag na hidden variable na ito kung matagpuan ay magresolba sa ilan sa tila paradohikal at probabilistikong
aspeto ng quantum mechanics sa kabilang kampo ay si Max Born iginiit ni Born
na ang probabilistikong paglalarawan na ibinibigay ng quantum mechanics ay lahat ng tinukoy ng kalikasan sa madaling salita
hindi lamang na hindi natin alam ang estado ng isang particle bago ito sukatin kundi ang particle ay walang tiyak na estado
bago ito sukatin sa loob ng maraming dekada, marami ang nag-isip na ang pagtatalo na ito ay isang pilosopikal na tanong na maaaring hindi
malulutas dahil upang matuto ng anumang bagay tungkol sa isang sistema kailangan nating sukatin ito paano tayo matututo
ng anumang bagay tungkol sa kalikasan ng isang estado bago ang pagsukat nito noong 1964, ang pisiko
na si John Bell ay nakahanap ng paraan sa kanyang papel sinuri ni Bell ang mga istatistikal na ugnayan sa pagitan ng mga sukat ng isang pares ng
mga naenganyo na particle kung bago ang pagsukat ang mga estado ng mga particle ay tinutukoy ng ilang hindi kilalang hidden
variable natuklasan ni Bell na ang kanilang mga ugnayan ay may itaas na limitasyon sa kabilang banda nang kinakalkula niya ang
mga ugnayan na hinulaang ng quantum mechanics natuklasan niya na lumabag sila sa limitasyong ito kaya nakahanap siya ng paraan upang
mapagkilala magpakailanman ang pananaw ni Einstein at Born lahat ng natitira ay ang aktwal na eksperimental na
pagsubok ng mga ugnayan na ito gamit ang mga tunay na particle upang makita kung sinusunod nila ang hidden variable na istatistika o
nilalabag ang patakarang iyon ang mga pagsubok na ito ay isinagawa nang may tumataas na katumpakan at kahusayan
sa loob ng mga taon at ang mga ito ay ilan sa pinakamahalaga na mga eksperimento ng modernong pisika napakarebolusyonaryo nila na
nakakuha sila ng Nobel Prize para sa tatlong pisiko noong 2022 ngunit ngayon kahit sino ay maaaring magsagawa ng
bell test lahat ng kailangan natin ay kaunting kaalaman sa Qiskit at access sa isang IBM quantum computer sa video na ito
ilalakad kita sa lohika ng Bell's inequality pagkatapos ay ipapakita ko sa iyo kung paano natin masusuri ang mga hula ni Bell sa isang IBM
quantum computer ang Bell's inequality ay kinabibilangan ng ilang iba't ibang sukat at mga antas ng lohika at maaari itong
maging medyo mahirap sundan ngunit daraan tayo rito hakbang sa hakbang at sa huli sulit ito handa tayong ipakita
na ang entanglement ay tunay at mali si Einstein hindi iyon magagawa ng maraming tao kaya narito
ang iminungkahi ni Bell sabihin nating mayroon kang paraan upang makagawa ng maraming kopya ng isang naenganyo na pares ng particle sa pisikal
na paraan ang mga pares na ito ay maaaring makagawa sa pamamagitan ng proseso ng Decay kung saan ang isang particle ay nag-decay sa dalawa kung napanood mo ang video sa
eksperimentong Stern-Gerlach alam mo na ang mga particle ay maaaring may likas na angular momentum na tinatawag na
spin sabihin nating ang isang spin zero particle ay nag-decay sa dalawang spin 1/2
particle pagkatapos ang bawat isa sa mga spin 1/2 na particle ay maaaring masukat upang magkaroon ng alinman spin plus 1/2 o minus
1/2 na tinatawag din na spin up o spin down ngunit dahil nag-decay sila mula sa isang spin zero na particle ang dalawa ay dapat na pagsamahin upang
magkaroon ng kabuuang spin na zero pati na rin kaya kung ang isa ay nasukat na up ang isa pa ay dapat na
down at vice versa ang mga particle na ito ay bumubuo ng isang naenganyo na pares na ganito ang hitsura
kaya kung ang isa ay nasukat na up ang isa pa ay down at vice versa sabihin nating ang particle isa ay lumipad sa kaliwa o
sa minus X direksyon kung saan susukat ng mananaliksik na tatawagin nating Lucas ang kanyang
spin pagkatapos ang particle dalawa ay katulad na lumilipad sa kanan
kung saan maaaring sukatin ni Rihanna ang spin na iyon si Lucas at Rihanna ay maaaring mag-independently
paikutin ang kanilang mga aparato sa pagsukat upang piliin na sukatin ang spin ng kanilang mga particle sa alinmang direksyon
na nakahalang sa direksyon ng galaw ng particle kung magpapadala tayo ng maraming kopya ng naenganyo na estado kay Lucas
at Rihanna maaari silang mangolekta ng mga istatistika ng pagsukat kung lagi silang sumusukat sa parehong axis ang mga istatistikang ito ay hindi
magiging kawili-wili sa tuwing ang isa ay sumusukat ng spin up ang isa pa ay sumusukat ng spin down at sa tuwing ang isa ay sumusukat ng spin
forward ang isa pa ay sumusukat ng spin backward at iba pa ngunit kung ang dalawang mananaliksik ay sumusukat sa iba't ibang axis maaari tayong makahanap ng
mas kawili-wiling bagay ibigay natin kay Lucas at Rihanna ang tatlong axis kung saan sila
susukat tatawagin natin ang mga axis na ito na a b at c at ang bawat isa ay pinaghihiwalay ng
120° ang tanong na itatanong natin sa eksperimentong ito ay kung si Lucas at Rihanna ay malaya na sumusukat sa alinman sa tatlong
axis gaano kadalas ang dalawa ay makakakuha ng parehong tanda malinaw na kung si Lucas at Rihanna ay pagkatapos sumusukat sa parehong axis
sabihin ang axis a hindi sila makakakuha ng parehong tanda dahil ang mga particle ay dapat pagsamahin upang magkaroon ng spin zero ngunit kapag pumili sila ng
iba't ibang axis kung paano magiging magkaugnay ang kanilang mga sukat kung mayroon man ayon kay Einstein ang quantum
mekanikal na paglalarawan ng estado ng particle ay hindi kumpleto inisip niya na dapat mayroong mga hidden variable na
nagtatakda ng resulta ng lahat ng posibleng sukat ng spin dahil kung wala iyon ang mga naenganyo na particle ay kailangan
na ilang paraan na ipahayag ang resulta ng kanilang pagsukat sa isa't isa nang agad-agad kung ang isa ay nasukat na
up doon sa kabilang panig ang isa pa ay dapat agad-agad na malaman na maging down dito
ang mga hidden variable na ito ay maaaring maging anumang kumplikadong hanay ng mga tagubilin para sa resulta ng mga eksperimento ngunit ang punto ay
ang spin state ng bawat particle nang hiwalay ay natutukoy kaya walang komunikasyon na kinakailangan
sa eksperimental na paraan ibig sabihin ang mga sukat na ginawa ni Lucas ay walang epekto sa particle ni Rihanna at vice
versa maaari itong maglagay ng ilang limitasyon sa kung gaano kamagkaugnay ang dalawang sukat ayon naman kay Born ang estado
na ito ay lahat ng maaaring sabihin tungkol sa pares ng mga particle bago ang pagsukat kaya ang pagsukat ng isang particle
ay nakakaapekto sa resulta ng pagsukat ng isa pa maaaring ito ay may iba't ibang implikasyon para sa mga ugnayan sa pagitan ng mga sukat tingnan natin kung paano ang bawat
teorya ay nakakaapekto sa mga ugnayan na ito sa paggamot ng hidden variable may isang lihim na hanay ng mga tagubilin bago ang
pagsukat na nagtatakda na kung ano ang susukakin ni Lucas sa bawat isa sa tatlong axis halimbawa ang mga
tagubiling ito ay maaaring positibo kung si Lucas ay sumusukat sa axis a
positibo kung sumusukat siya sa B at negatibo kung sumusukat siya sa c maaari nating
isulat ito bilang plus a plus b at minus c pagkatapos ang particle ni Rihanna
ay kailangang magkaroon ng mga variable na minus a minus b at plus c upang matiyak na ang kabuuan
ng spin sa anumang iisang direksyon ay zero
mayroong walong hanay ng posibleng tagubilin na nakakatugon sa spin zero na hadlang na ito kaya sa bawat pagkakataon na ang isang bagong pares ng
mga particle ay ipinapadala kay Lucas at Rihanna maaari itong maglaman ng alinman sa walong hanay ng mga tagubiling ito kaya ngayon nais nating
malaman batay sa pagpapalagay na ang mga particle ay naglalaman ng isa sa mga lihim na hanay ng mga tagubilin na ibinibigay sa talahanayan at
batay sa pagpapalagay na si Lucas at Rihanna ay bawat isa ay nakapag-iisang pumili kung alin sa tatlong axis ang susukatin ano ang
probabilidad na pareho silang makakakuha ng parehong tanda kung ang mga tagubilin ay yaong nasa mga row 1 o
8 malinaw na ang probabilidad na ito ay zero dahil ang dalawang particle ay magkakaroon ng magkasalungat na tanda anuman ang kanilang
mga axis ng pagsukat ngunit paano ang mga tagubilin sa row dalawa susukat sila ng parehong tanda kung
sumukat si Rihanna sa c at sumukat si Lucas sa alinman sa a o b o kung si Lucas
ay sumukat sa c at si Rihanna ay sumukat sa alinman sa A o B kaya iyon ay apat sa siyam ng
mga posibleng kombinasyon ng pagsukat na magbibigay kay Lucas at Rihanna ng parehong tanda kung gagawin natin ito para sa
bawat hanay ng mga tagubilin makikita mo na ang mga Row 3 hanggang 7 ay nagbibigay din ng probabilidad na 4/9 ibig sabihin kung
tama si Einstein at ang mga hidden variable tulad ng mga ito ay nagtatakda ng resulta ng mga sukat walang paraan para kay Lucas
at Rihanna na masukat ang parehong tanda na may probabilidad na mas malaki sa 4/9 ito ang Bell inequality P na mas mababa sa
o katumbas ng 4/9 at gaya ng ating ipapakita ang mga naenganyo na particle ay lumalabag dito kaya upang
makita kung ano ang hinulaang ng quantum mechanics sabihin nating sumukat si Lucas sa a maaaring mangyari ang dalawang bagay alinman ay sumukat siya ng spin up kaya
si Rihanna ay susukat ng spin down sa a o sumukat siya ng spin down at si Rihanna ay susukat ng spin up sa a ngunit gusto
natin ang probabilidad na si Rihanna ay sumusukat ng parehong tanda tulad ni Lucas sa alinmang axis ng kanyang pagpili hindi lamang a kung
sumusukat siya sa alinman sa B o C ito ay magiging medyo kumplikado pala
kung alam mo kung ano ang susukakin ni Rihanna nang may 100% katiyakan sa isang direksyon maaari mong kalkulahin ang mga probabilidad
na susukat siya ng up o down sa anumang ibang axis gamit ang kaunting geometry
kung ang iyong estado ay laging sumusukat ng spin up sa isang axis ang probabilidad ng pagsukat ng spin up sa ibang axis
ay katumbas ng kwadrado ng cosine ng 1/2 ng anggulo sa pagitan ng dalawang axis medyo kumplikado iyon ngunit
ipapakita ko sa iyo kung ano ang ibig kong sabihin kung sumukat si Lucas ng spin up sa a alam natin nang may 100% katiyakan na si Rihanna ay susukat ng
spin down kung susukat siya sa a kaya maaari nating katawanin iyon gamit ang isang vector
ganito sa kasong ito ang mga anggulo sa pagitan ng vector na ito at ng iba pang dalawang axis ng pagsukat B at C ay parehong
60° kaya ang 1/2 nito ay 30° at ang cosine ng
30 ay ipinapakita dito cosine squared ng
30° ay katumbas ng 3/4 ngayon paano kung sumukat si Lucas ng spin down
sa a alam nating susukat si Rihanna ng spin up sa a kaya maaari tayong gumuhit ng isa pang vector dito ngayon
ang vector na ito na kumakatawan sa kaalamang ito ay 120° mula sa bawat isa sa iba pang dalawang axis B
at C kaya maaari nating gawin ang parehong trick sa geometry ngunit sa pagkakataong ito makakakuha tayo ng cosine ng
60° kaya ang cosine squared ng
60° ay katumbas ng 1/4 dahil si Lucas ay pantay na malamang na
sumukat ng spin up at spin down sa a kailangan nating i-average ang dalawang probabilidad na ito ni Rihanna magtatapos tayo sa isang huling
probabilidad na si Rihanna ay susukat ng parehong tanda tulad ni Lucas na 1/2 kaya P
ay katumbas ng 1/2 ang 1/2 ay mas malaki sa 4/9 kaya ang Bell's inequality ay nilalabag
ibig sabihin hanggang sa patuloy na nangunguna ang mga tuntunin ng quantum mechanics ang mga hidden variable ay imposible ngayon maaari tayong gumamit ng Qiskit at isang
IBM quantum computer upang subukan ang Bell inequality gamit ang mga tunay na quantum na sukat maaari nating i-map ang spin up at
spin down na mga estado ng mga particle ni Lucas at Rihanna sa zero at isa na mga estado ng mga qubit sa quantum computer
kukuha tayo ng dalawang qubit ang isa para katawanin ang particle ni Lucas at isa para kay Rihanna at pag-enganyuhin sila gamit ang quantum circuit na ito
kaya ang dalawang qubit ay kinakatawan ng dalawang wire q0 at q1 at ang kombinasyong ito
ng X Hadamard at c not gate ay gagawa ng parehong naenganyo na estado na mayroon tayo sa pagitan ng mga particle ni Lucas at Rihanna ngayon
kailangan nating sukatin ang bawat qubit itatakda natin ang sukat ni Lucas sa a na sasabihin nating ay ang Z axis pagkatapos ang sukat ni Rihanna
ay maaaring nasa a b o c kaya kakailanganin nating may tatlong hiwalay na circuit para sa bawat isa sa tatlong kasong ito ngunit sa
video na ito gagawin lamang natin ang isa maaari kang pumunta sa module na naka-link sa paglalarawan para sa buong bagay kung sumukat si Rihanna sa
B ang aming circuit ay ganito kung saan ang ry ay isang pag-ikot ng 120 degrees upang baguhin
ang axis ng pagsukat ni Rihanna maaari nating gamitin ang Qiskit Primitive sampler upang patakbuhin ang eksperimentong ito nang maraming beses at mangolekta ng
mga istatistika mula sa mga resultang sukat ang dalawang hanay 0 0 at 1 1 ay kumakatawan sa mga oras na si Lucas at
Rihanna ay nasukat ng parehong tanda na iyon ang hinahanap natin kaya ang probabilidad ng pagsukat ng parehong particle na may
parehong tanda ay halos katumbas ng 1/2 ito ay lumalabag sa Bell's inequality ibig sabihin nito
na ang dalawang particle ay naenganyo ang bawat isa ay tila agad-agad na nalalaman ang mga resulta ng
pagsukat ng isa pa mayroon pa ring ilang hindi pagkakasundo tungkol sa kung paano eksaktong i-interpret ito
na entanglement at kung ano ang nangyayari kapag sinukat mo ang isang naenganyo na estado ngunit ang mga tanong na ito ay mas pilosopikal
ang teorya ay halos hindi mapagtatanggolan sa puntong ito ang entanglement ay talagang tunay at nalalaman natin ito salamat kay Bell sa kanyang
inequality at sa maraming pisiko na nagsagawa ng mga eksperimento upang subukan ito kung nais mong mabilang sa mga
pisikong iyon at magsagawa ng iyong sariling Bell test gamit ang isang quantum computer siguraduhing pumunta sa bells inequality module
na naka-link sa paglalarawan salamat sa panood at makikita kita sa susunod